fundamentally I'm a writer the big goal
that has been under a dress for a long
time it's writing my next book
everything right now is working really
really well the podcast is successful
it's impacting so many people cool
opportunities are flowing in you know
very much a type-a personality I'm
driven I'm competitive if you give me a
mountain to climb I'll tell you you know
I need a higher one or once I climb it I
want to immediately identify the next
one when I sit down and think about how
do I want to spend my time the calculus
that I run is how is this going to be a
positive force for good in the world
training and racing makes me feel me and
in certain respects it is it is sort of
an artistic performance art expression
you know I certainly don't care how fast
I can go and even more I think that time
is better spent trying to impact people
in a positive way
and I do that through the podcast
through the public speaking engagements
that I do and the retreats and the
products and the books that we put out
into the world but with the creative
stuff it's definitely been a struggle
I think in retrospect looking back over
the last several years I think that I've
created this whole podcast as a
distraction to conveniently opt out of
having to write another book and I'm so
terrified of it that I will do anything
I'll train for some crazy ultra race or
I will spend six years interviewing
people just so I don't have to be with
myself and the written page that is the
resistance that Steven Pressfield talks
about in the war of art I certainly have
that and perhaps there's a little fear
around putting ass in chair and writing
and what that might look like and how
that might be perceived and that's my
that's my mountain to climb to get over
that to summon up the courage and the
compunction to create the thing that
will lead me into the next chapter of
what I do I mean certainly I'm not
abandoning the podcast I'll continue to
do it but I think if I really want to
impact the number of people that I
believe I'm capable of impacting I think
it is important that I write another
book and I have things that I want to
say
I think we have this sense that we have
to have the roadmap all figured out
before we take that first step and we
need to know what it looks like and we
need to have that vision board and
having the fortitude to let go of
whatever story it is you tell yourself
about who you are and what that needs to
look like have been probably the most
powerful teachers for me
[Music]
you